- Wait, do you like me?
- Of course.
- What's my name?
- Sarah.
- It's Jenny.
- [Man] That's what I meant to say.
- Fuck you. (chuckling)
- [Man] I swear Jenny was my next guess.
- Okay,
I'm gonna sleep with you,
but you're a fucking asshole.
(instrumental rock music)
- You want to go to breakfast?
- Oh, sorry.
I have to finish up some homework.
- Do you want to go to
the movies with me later?
- Oh sorry, I have to take
my buddy to the airport.
(instrumental rock music)
- You want to go out sometime?
- Sorry,
I have an appointment.
- I never gave you a date.
(instrumental rock music)
(church bells ringing)
- Hey, this was really fun.
- Yeah, we should go
have a drink sometime.
- Oh I have to take my friend
to the airport, actually.
- I never said a time.
- I just have a really busy month.
(phone ringing)
- Yo, what up man?
Glad you're still alive.
You chugged enough Fireball
for the whole party.
And then some. (chuckling)
Yeah, actually, her name was Madison.
I don't know, I think I'm gonna
hang back tonight, actually.
Got some homework to finish up.
(instrumental rock music)
- Cheers (mumbling).
Fucking apple cider.
- [Man In Black Hat] Yeah
I'm not down for this.
- No. (chuckling)
- [Man In Black Hat] Not at all.
I'm gonna go to the
bathroom, I'll be right back.
- Yeah.
- [Madison] Thank you for this.
- Yeah, so you were checking up on school,
everything good this semester, for you?
- (Laughing) Yeah,
everything's perfectly fine.
- Yeah, nice, nice, I just
wanted to make sure you're--
- [Elliot] Hey, Madison.
- Hey, Eli.
- Elliot, from.
- Oh yeah.
- Last night slash this morning.
- Yeah, this is John from tonight.
- Hey.
- Can I talk to you?
- Sure.
- For a second?
- Sorry.
- Hey, what's up?
- Nothing.
What's going on?
- You haven't texted me back.
- Oh, yeah, I told you I was busy.
- Busy with him?
- Yeah, is that a problem?
- No, it was just,
I thought we had a good time.
- Yeah, we did, we had a lot of fun.
So we should hang out again.
- Sure, okay, but tonight I'm
hanging out with John, so.
- When do we get to hang out?
- I don't know, I'll text you, okay?
- Hey, you don't have a
very good track record
of doing that.
- Okay, Elliot.
Can I be honest with you?
- [Elliot] Please.
- Last night I was drunk,
and I thought you were
really cute, so I hooked up with you.
But isn't that your Thursday night routine
with girls around here?
- That's not true.
- Really?
- No.
- Okay.
Well, I just got out of a
relationship really recently
and I don't want a boyfriend, and I guess
you were just there.
- I was your rebound.
- I had a really, really good time.
I just don't want
somebody buying me brunch.
- I'm sorry, I'm just,
this has never happened to me before, so.
- Really, (chuckling) oh no,
I hope you didn't think I was gonna fall
madly in love with you or something.
- No.
- [Madison] Okay, well did
you fall in love with me?
- No.
- Okay, so we're good then.
- [Elliot] Yeah.
- Friends?
- Friends.
- Cool, you want to join
John and I for a drink?
- I'm good.
- Okay, I'll see you around.
Hey, sorry about that,
yeah, it's totally fine.
Tell me the rest of the
story about Iceland.
- Yeah, so okay, so we're
driving up this hill
(mumbling) all these crazy (mumbling).
- Mhm.